all right overwatch too it is still a
game that people are excited for last
week the games director announced a beta
and gave us a big update on what's
coming up for the game the first news
we've heard about it in months so let's
break down everything we know about
overwatch 2 and why i'm genuinely
worried about this game
[Music]
alright folks before we get into the
video i just want to remind you all to
please sub to the channel and turn on
notifications if you haven't done it yet
because it really does help okay so
overwatch 2 got announced all the way
back in november 2019 at blizzcon amidst
a ton of bad news coming out of blizzard
notably bad news has not stopped coming
out of blizzard since then anyway the
idea was that one of the big upgrades
for the sequel was that overwatch 2 was
going to have an increased focus on pve
content something that casual players
really enjoyed but didn't always have
access to in the base game they
announced a new character sojourn and
that basically every old character was
getting a visual redesign which so far
has mostly involved making them all
uglier and more complicated i mean what
the [ __ ] were they thinking with mercy's
new haircut look at this this is a woman
who is demanding to talk to your manager
i hate it then they announced some
character reworks which is going to
include taking characters like sombra
and doomfist down a peg and then just
under a year ago they announced that the
pvp parts of the game were moving to 5v5
down one player from overwatch 1 6 v6
after that we didn't really hear
anything it's basically been a radio
silence since may 2021 but then last
week the game's third director aaron
keller was featured in a video making
some pretty big announcements first they
are separating at least for now the pvp
and pve aspects of overwatch too that's
going to let them start beta testing in
a private beta for blizzard employees
and their key partners like overwatch
league pros in april that beta is going
to open up to the public and sign ups
are open now the beta is gonna feature
four new maps four new character reworks
the new push gameplay mode and the new
ping system side note one of those new
maps is the toronto map they announced
forever ago but now we finally know that
it is called new queen street
what the [ __ ] happened to old queen
street also what is tim fordson's did
our premiere somehow buy out tim hortons
in the future and how the does our
subway ever end up looking like this
inquiring minds demand to know anyway
keller ended the video by promising that
they're going to be more updates in the
future and that overwatch players are
going to be a bigger part of the design
process going forward he also said that
the reason there's been such a dearth of
content for overwatch one lately is
because most of the dev team has been
hard at work on overwatch 2 and
basically leaving the original game
dying on the vine keller apologized for
that he said there's gonna be more
communication in the future and that
this new process is gonna let the dev
team deliver more pvp content updates to
overwatch one
but that's where i get a little confused
see back when overwatch 2 was announced
then game director jeff kaplan promised
that overwatch 1 and 2 will have a quote
shared multiplayer environment where no
one gets left behind all new maps and
characters are going to come to
overwatch 1. i'm assuming that also
means overwatch 1 players are going to
get the 5v5 gameplay mode and any
balance updates while the single player
content will be exclusive to overwatch
2. and this is where they totally lose
me because at this point why does
overwatch 2 even exist why aren't they
just i don't know updating overwatch one
and adding content to it the answer is
money of course but i feel like they'd
make more of it and spend less of it if
they just did all these pvp updates to
overwatch one they're doing anyway for
free and releasing like a pve battle
pass or something alongside it the game
can't feel significantly different in a
way that's going to attract a massive
new player base because they have to run
on the same engine they're
cross-compatible for multiplayer and
there's no way pvp and pve run on
totally different engines that would be
an insane amount of work for basically
no reward at the same time they are
completely changing the original game
with all these reworks the new maps the
new characters and the 5v5 gameplay that
is also an insane amount of work and
while it's really cool that they're
going to still support the original game
that makes it really hard to justify
buying the sequel from my perspective
what are overwatch 1 players not getting
skins and pve content right so basically
the brand new presumably 60 plus dollar
video game is a glorified skin pack for
anyone not interested in the pve content
and at the same time i'm someone who
genuinely liked the pve stuff in
overwatch one and it's impossible for me
to justify buying overwatch 2 because i
already own half the game i bought it
back in 2016 when it was called
overwatch one genuinely what the [ __ ]
was you're doing i don't understand to
give you even more of a headache the
upcoming season of the overwatch league
is going to be played on the overwatch 2
beta which makes sense it's open to the
public so everyone can play but then
keller said that there are going to be
more betas in the future which means
this upcoming one isn't going to be up
indefinitely that's going to mean that
there are probably going to be some
moments when the overwatch league is
playing a game that you literally can't
play at home and that's not necessarily
a bad thing it's just really weird and
confusing and sort of goes against the
whole idea that an esports league is a
giant ad for your game look overwatch 2
has been a mess it's gone through three
different directors since being
announced the game it's a sequel to
isn't a state of disrepair it has
trouble justifying its existence and we
didn't hear anything about it for almost
a year and to top it all off blizzard is
one of the most hated companies in
gaming right now due to all the
allegations of horrible sexism
discrimination and harassment happening
at the company the announcement that
people are finally gonna get to try
overwatch 2 after all these years is
probably great for those people who are
somehow still overwatch fans after all
these years and you know what i bet the
game's gonna be good it's probably gonna
be really fun if not as revolutionary as
the original but as someone who played
overwatch religiously back in 2016 and
2017
i'm not hearing anything that's pulling
me back in worse i'm concerned because
blizzard basically killed overwatch when
they ended support for it and started
working on overwatch too and now all the
new pvp content they were working on is
coming to overwatch one anyway i have no
real reason to buy overwatch 2.
hopefully the update gives me a new fun
reason to play this game i've already
owned for 6 years but honestly i'm more
confused and concerned about overwatch
than ever
[Music]
i don't think i ever actually listened
to that song i had a friend who heard it
and because i was playing a lot of
overwatch would like make jokes about
that song and
they're not a particularly good singer
and so it was very annoying and so it
never made me go and listen to the
actual song when you worked at the score
esports offices especially in 2016 2017
it was really a hermetically sealed like
yogurt tub of irony and so to listen to
something like that that was like oh
that's like the popular meme we can't do
that